bonjour bienvenue sur des modèles tv
pour la suite de ce championnat du monde
2016 donc entre banyuls carcelle le
tenant du titre pièces blanches et
sergueï kaliakine pièce noire le
challenger
donc au niveau du classement on est sur
la deuxième partie c'est la dernière
partie longue du match on a donc ici
voilà je vous ai mis le déplacement ils
sont à égalité 5 ennemis partout donc
avec victoire dans la huitième pour car
yakine égalisation in extremis de carsen
dans la 10e et donc une nulle à la 11e
partie est donc ici c'est donc cette
deuxième partie qui peut être décisif
bien sûr le joueur qui l'emportent et
champion du monde
en cas d'égalité et bien ils devront
jouer des tie break alors on n'en est
pas là car scène à l'eiblen c'est parti
avec aller 1-4
comme dans tout le match quasiment oui
allez c'est parti voilà donc c'est
vraiment un match à bath 2,4 on peut
même dire que c'est un match rue lopez
parce que on n'a eu quasiment que des e
4 e 5 nf3 calisesi sous b 5
alors est-ce que ça va suivre encore ça
donc on a eu deux deux parties et puis
honda mine semble peut-être 3 mai
il faudra compter mais pour l'instant
c'est vraiment dur une opel a alors eu
cinq cas bf3 cavalli c6 et la poule b 5
ça y est encore une rue lopez alors là
c'est karine calais nord il a l'habitude
de répondre par la défense de berlin le
fameux mur de berlin avec ayem 6
popularisé donc pas par kramnik lors de
son mathieu contre contre kasparov
alors que car c'est lui joue la grande
arène de l'espagnol avec à six qui
chasse car c'est lui donc à 6 pour
chasser le fou voilà donc lors la ccara
qui non concertée en qualifs 6
et voilà ça rate pas qu'avec six mois là
donc là bon - ils suivent leur
préparation on sent qu'ils sont très
très préparé donc là on sent quand même
un championnat du monde à l'ancienne un
retour il faut dire que cariat kiné
russe alors ça doit jouer sa danse à son
approche du match de jouer comme ça avec
cette technique russe depuis des
champions du monde depuis peut-être ali
kinball binic voilà pascali qui n'était
reçoit français déjà et puis a pris
bobigny qu'on est quasiment que des
russes sont fischer voilà et c'était des
matches comme ça voilà où les joueurs
insistez beaucoup sur les ouvertures
donc petit rock de carsen on a déjà vu
ça car les prend on les fait tout tout
de suite
cavaliers des 6 et alors là kasparov a
eu pris l'habitude lille de prendre le
cavalier ici ce qui double et des pions
et qu'arsenal a déjà montré
voilà il prend 2,25 et lens il est noir
prennent regarder ça c'est un piège on
regarde ça allez un petit piège si les
noirs prennent le fou qui est en prise
c'est une grosse faute pourquoi pas se
regarder là il va y avoir un échec de la
tour donc je peux mettre le cavalier ou
je veux ça s'appelle la niche et que la
découverte et le roi sera michel ange
pour aller prendre là tôt en venant à
angers 6 et les prendre la tour mais à
mieux
je prends simplement pouf ici le
cavalier par le clavier je prends échec
est en somme un échec mais la dame est
attaqué voilà et même si on met la dame
devant on le prend duquel on l'apprend
du cavalier on ne prend même pas de la
tour donc c'est un massacre c'est pas la
peine de continuer à partie donc sauf
qu'à aller prendre 5 c'est pourquoi les
noirs peuvent pas prendre le fou et donc
il joue alors on pourrait ici pour jouer
cavalier prend 1,5
plutôt que de jouer le coup suivant qui
est bien aussi c'est un peu moi ça
change pas grand chose voilà fouet cette
fosse est hélas carsen revient fn voilà
voilà donc c'est une façon de jouer
cette cette défense de berlin
intéressante l'idée des blancs c'est
qu'il laisse les noirs avec un accueil
mal placée ce cas l'aider si cela qui
est devant le pion de sortie du fou le
blanchissent idées noires pouces et 8 a
du mal à sortir ce ses venelles naturel
ici puisque pour rouge espions faudra
d'abord embauché le cabinet voilà un
petit avantage mais on a des structures
de pions symétrique aussi alors que
quand on prend le cavalier en double bon
mais on donne la paire de fou voilà donc
les avantages inconvénients
alors les noirs maintenant prêts nous
aurions pu prendre tout de suite tout à
l'heure aux citrons ça marche et c'est
pareil et la tour prend et petit rock
voilà n'ont pas de problème pour les
noirs sauf ce problème de cavaliers
voilà qui génère
d4 de carson naturel normal un des
quatre ont même pu en sueur le sang
contre la casse de 5
et bien sûr on prépare la sortie du fou
c'est un coût tout à fait naturel avec
qui pose pas de problème de
compréhension
la fouille 6 très bon coup j'attaque la
tour un petit oeil sur des 4
et puis je peux commencer à changer des
pièces par tours 8 plus je change de
pièce - le la base de développement des
blancs sera sera importante sûrement ils
pourront monter d'attac aussi tôt 1
et voilà tout huit bons mais voilà
tranquille où on a eu droit il me semble
bien une simplicité exactement une
position il ya eu autour d'eux on
l'avait vue dont deux des six taureaux 1
c'était un peu curieux de carsen vous
reverrez la partie chez lui à quai c'est
exactement vallée dans le match voilà
donc tour ou indirecte et la tour 1 8
ici car scène joue fou s 4 il faut être
quatre bah oui attaque le cavalier
menace fou prend avec doublement des
pions alors sur noir de jouer
ils prennent en main d'abord la prend et
l'aller les noirs auraient pu prendre en
d4 là c'est intéressant ça qu'est ce qui
se serait passé sur fou prend des quatre
alors c'est parce qu'ils ont joué
il ya un pion en prise alors évidemment
ce qu'on se dit tout de suite c'est que
lecavalier et en d6 on peut le prendre
en décident tout simplement
alors si on prend le cavalier il faut
calculer c'est pas simple parce que les
noirs pourraient prendre en b deux
attaquants la tour laissant le fou des
six attaques et alors imaginons ici
fonds prend fou prend b2 pour voir ce
qui se passe dans ce cas là les blancs
on l'a déjà vu cette variante dans tous
similaires presque la même un fou procès
7 et la dame ne peut pas prendre le fou
puisqu'il ya matt peut pas les dents en
or 8 puisque la dame se serait perdu il
reste dames et fuite
et là on peut jouer simplement tout
simplement sur ces pièces c'est jouable
on sort ses pièces et on n'a pas peur
d'eux
alors faut prendre un à un normal les
blancs prennent voilà c'est important
ici c'est qu'on contrôle le cavaly sinon
ils madame c5 est en train de me dire qu
attaques de pièces mais non ça tape pas
le cavalier donc çà et là les blancs
bombés ont deux fous contre la tour si
on veut le cavalier et en étant à
égalité pour le foot donc c'est mieux
pour les blancs voyez mais c'est une
partie intéressante quand même c'est
jouable encore ça même si c'est quand
même avantage ou blanc net mais ici donc
faut prendre les six on n'est pas obligé
de prendre b2 les noirs pouvaient aussi
prendre des six variantes ici puis
reprendre des 6 1 ce cas là les blancs
jouent ces 3 mai pour chasser le fou et
le fou va ans
6 pas rien alors on a doublé des pions
adverse mais si elle tourne plus aussi
bon montage inconvénients et puis les
noirs ont la fameuse paire de fous où
l'aca reste que je jouais pas mal parce
que il ya de l'air quand même voilà il
ya pas mal de cases dans ce four on
adorerait le mettre sur bessette et ça
doit être assez facile à faire
voilà donc donc sans doute une partie
équilibrée mais intéressante
1 - au moins on a une structure assez
asymétrique messi sans doute pas facile
à de jouer ça avec les blancs je sais
même pas je sais pas si nous voulons
peuvent tirer avantage de sa et depuis
on peut la paire de foot doit compenser
on va dire ça
donc tout reprend 1,1 d'un prend 20 est
ici donc les noirs ne prennent pas des
quatre et ils jouent donc le plus simple
naturelle tranquille qu'à lieu huit mois
la cara qui ne prend aucun risque
ils jouent à la rue ce classique voilà
il replace son cavalier puisqu'il est
mal placée à noter que sur foot français
c'est évident on peut prendre du
cavalier sinon et si on prenait de la
dame évidemment lequel il sera en prise
de la dame blanche
voilà donc la 15 minutes pourquoi on
veut jouer des six tout simplement des
six pour restreindre ce fou de voir
qu'il tape pas sur ces sept là on va
jouer des six
on pourrait même jouer des scènes que je
suis en train de me dire aussi jouer des
5 avec l'idée derrière ces six peut-être
est tout simplement et après on sortira
le fou en finale par un lecavalier des
six mois de juin mais aussi voilà donc
tranquille les blancs maintenant bon et
maintenant le pion des quatre attaques
et donc ils défendent avec ses trois
très bien et la voilà justement voilà
les noirs ou des cinq et non pas des six
mois c'est sans doute mieux parce qu'en
plus des espaces et on peut mettre le
cavalier sur une bonne case aussi voilà
on décide parce que si on joue des six
ce qui me gênait ce qui gêne très
certainement car yakine aussi bien sûr
c'est que il est le cas les peut pas
sortir là toutes les cases sont prises a
largement de dessins qu'il a une
le casse de sortie fou des trois
naturels bon tu dire on rejoue fou mais
bon c'est vrai c'est pour sans doute
pour empêcher les noirs de mettre leur
fonte un f5 voilà on joue d'abord tout
de suite fou détroit pour éviter au noir
collé devant est une case naturel pour
leur fout là c'est plus dur trouver une
bonne place pour le fou sa bonne des
modèles c'est celle là parce que ici il
peut se faire chasser
h3 et sa gaffe sa part une gagner du
temps pour les blancs puis après il va
ou en 17
il n'a pas dit il peut pas trouver
diagonale sur l' on sait s'il est bloqué
par son pion en bessin qui peut pas le
fou aura quatre y fit rien donc voilà
c'est voilà donc fou détroit je pense
est important c'est pas mal joué j'ai 6
alors j'ai six l'idée c'est pas
tellement doué fou et 5 tout de suite
mais ça peut être de jouer cavalier g7
pour ensuite jouer fouet 5
voilà aussi je cale et des six
communautés aussi que j'ai six empêche
la taxe leurs suffrages sept ans la dame
il faudrait que la dame puisse venir
mais ne peut pas attention et déjà mal
placé là pour attaquer c'était en tout
cas voilà donc ici qu'à ya trois
normales bon sur les pièces où le
cavalier à plusieurs cases naturel à 3
pour quoi bon s'en doute les noirs
peuvent jouer ses 6 c'est ce qu'ils vont
faire d'ailleurs donc du coup le cas n a
pas de case en bessin ou là donc du coup
la seule idée qu'on peut avoir en jouant
ce cavalière 3,1 à 3,6 le mètres en c-2
voilà en c2 wifi rien de spécial parce
que si vivante 3 way pas terrible je
vois pas ce qu'il fait on trop non plus
parce qu'il est dominé par les pions
bien du mal à trouver une bonne car on
fait des sorties en tout cas on va
pouvoir jouer la tour peut-être donc ici
qu'a laissé deux et maintenant voilà
qu'à mais j'ai cette voie là pour jouer
aussi cavalier des silices peut-être
mais qu'elle agisse est c'est plus sûr
parce que kyle et 6 pour jouer au f5
c'est un petit problème parce que ça
laisse les blancs envisager de prendre
d'abord lecavalier avant de prendre f5
en tout cas ça fait sa demande des
calculs mais en jouant g7 ya pas de
problème là on pourra jouer sur cinq
sans se poser de question d'âme des deux
et voilà 5
aucun problème pour les noirs là ça y
est toutes les pièces sont sortis le fou
de cases blanches et noires là le fou de
casement chez super bien il a trouvé sa
meilleure des gones aly ci propose un
échange avec le fou detroit on voit mal
comment on peut éviter les changes
on peut certainement pas donc les choses
dit d'échangés bon ils n'ont pas trop le
choix de toute façon vous prend s'il
aurait pu ajouter you 3 le cahier pas
super bien passé en trois ans de toute
façon qu à l epr un cahier prend un f5
et maintenant qu'avec trois ans lassé
signature de nul vraiment là parce que
là on échange tout mais dans les noirs
saute sur l'occasion cavale et prend
dans prend il s'est rien passé l'un dams
est grave ça y est il ya tout qui
s'échangent
bon c'est sûr que là d'un prend fou
prend tôt
ces passifs tout ça et a tout simplement
tout de suite et la tour peut pas venir
pénétrer dans le camp ne reste à trouver
une façon d'attirer cet os un pack très
dur parce qu'on va jouer sans doute f5
en mettant tous les pions sont cases
blanches couleurs opposées de notre fou
on met le roi henri vii
et puis ensuite on autour de 8 et la
finale est archi nul c'est même presque
les blogs sont un peu moins bien puisque
sur leurs pions ici sur 15 mois mais bon
pour l'attaqué ça faut quand même
cherchons b2 on voit pas trop con le fou
peut venir taquiner un parce que tant
que ce fou reste la tasse on pourrait
faire y a pas de faiblesse - ouais enfin
voilà f6 voilà les baignoires joue même
pas un âge où m6 pour enlever des cases
aux fous ici ou fausse 4 1 voilà n'est
pas de danger g4 même pire on garde un
pion sur blanc on est 7 h 3 encore un
pur sur blanc à noter un couleurs
opposées du fonds de 8,1 tout reprendra
prend re 2 3 17
roi des 3 voilà les deux joueurs
savaient déjà que c'est archi nul ça
rien à faire si aucune faiblesse
on pourrait faire avec les fous on peut
pas passer en plus cela est tellement de
pions que laurent peut pas passer moi
aussi on joue les pions seront risque de
s'affaiblir soi même voilà donc il
voulut rien faire a4 a6 sera dé tous les
pires en quasiment un tous sauf le pion
ici sont tous sur casse blanche et
pareil pour les blancs quasiment rien
que les purs là mais le roi et réveil va
tranquillement façon et aucune faiblesse
trois voiliers regardez comme
méticuleusement les grands joueurs on va
la mettre leurs pions de la couleur
opposée de celle du fou des fous et 7
nuls en 30 coup les deux joueurs signent
là nul ici voilà alors une partie qui a
duré moins de deux heures 1h 1h30 je
crois que c'est comme ça au mur 45
donc c'est un peu décevant parce que il
s'est rien passé dans cette partie s'est
vraiment bien passé de cette partie
c'est un peu une redite précédente
mais la cara qui n'est pas tombé dans le
piège ou car senna n'a pas joué son coup
bizarre à tour aux deux là qui
finalement ce n'était peut-être pas si
c'est bizarre que ça il a poussé les
noirs à faire un développement curieux
et peut-être c'est ça il essaye de
pousser dans la faute je sais pas mais
en tout cas là il n'a pas réussi donc
les deux joueurs se retrouvent à égalité
après douze parties après cette dernière
partie vraiment dans la moins combative
du match s'attendait à mieux de carsen
quand même essayer de trouver là de
punch et la scène derrière parti et donc
non il va y va a joué son titre dans les
tie breaks
c'est risqué quand même un peu mais bon
pourquoi pas en partie rapide donc alors
je connais pas les règles exactes du tie
break on verra ça plus tard ses journées
de repos mardi
et donc les tie breaks ont lu mercredi à
noter aussi qu'il ya une journée de
repos avant cette deuxième partie que je
trouve anti sportive puisque toutes les
parties étaient deux parties d'affilée
suivi d'un jour de repos ça c'est au
moins le rythme est respecté et
bizarrement sauf pour la dernière il ya
eu un jour de repos supplémentaire et ça
c'est curieux c'est ça va avantager l'un
ou l'autre sans doute
peut-être les noirs justement parce que
bon avec la fatigue c'est déjà un peu
plus dangereux avec les noirs et la
fatigue peut-être encore plus en donne
un jour de repos supplémentaire celui
qu'il est noir dernier peut-être un
avantage ou même vers je sais pas
fondées faire beaucoup de matches en
comparant deux systèmes pour voir lequel
avantageux l'autre faudrait faire des
expériences pour ça mais bon on les fera
jamais mais en tout cas c'est bizarre
ethiquement c'est bizarre que quand même
les deux dernières parties échappe aux
règles qui ont été faites de tout le
match précédent dans tout l'est tous les
temps toutes les parties précédentes du
match il ya vingt jours de repos que
toutes les deux parties évidemment il y
en a eu deux jours de repos avec deux
parties intercalé 11 et 12 bon bref
voilà donc petit petit rappel donc 6 6
en 12 parties bon c'est quand même beau
match à part cette dernière lacune pas
terrible on croit que vous être
convaincus et tie break donc là ça va
être chaud quand même ça va être beau à
voir
mercredi ce qui va se passer en partie
rapide il peut se passer un peu
n'importe quoi
et voilà championnat du monde qui va se
joueur rapide c'est pas c'est pas
toujours c'est pas toujours ça arrive
assez rarement c'est assez récent déjà
comme règle est assez rare voilà merci
de m'avoir suivi sur diagonale tv donc
pour ce championnat du monde 2016 pour
ses 12 premières parties rendez vous
pour la suite pour les tie breaks au
revoir